hi everyone this is Professor MDOT
science and today I want to talk about
Dirac notation in the state space this
is another video in our series of
rigorous quantum mechanics state space
is the name that we give to the vector
space in which quantum systems live just
like Euclidean space is the name that we
give to the vector space in which we
describe classical physics state space
is a bit different to the usual
Euclidean space rather than having three
dimensions you can have more dimensions
in fact you can have infinite dimensions
another difference is that vectors in
state space are not described by real
numbers they're described by complex
numbers but they're also some
similarities we want to be able to
describe operation on vectors in both
Euclidean space and state space so in
both spaces we define a scalar or in a
product a vector space equipped with an
inner product is something we call a
Hilbert space describing operations in
the state space is made simple by a
notation first introduced by Paul Dirac
one of the founders of quantum mechanics
in this Dirac notation we use names like
cats bras and brackets that you may have
heard about so in this video I want to
introduce state space the vector space
in which quantum systems live I will
draw an analogy between state space and
the familiar three dimensional Euclidean
space and I will also introduce the rack
notation to describe vectors in state
space so let's get started state space
is the space in which quantum systems
live and therefore you can imagine it is
fundamental in the study of quantum
mechanics
indeed it features in the very first
postulate of quantum theory this
postulate tells us that the state of a
physical system is characterized by a
state vector and that if state vector
belongs to a complex vector space V
which we call the state space of the
system this postulate tells us that the
mathematical framework in which quantum
states live is a vector space so let's
start by getting a refresher about
vector spaces to do that we're going to
draw an analogy between a familiar
vector space the Euclidian
three-dimensional space r3 and this new
state space V that we have introduced to
describe quantum systems when drawing
this analogy we're also going to
introduce Dirac notation which is a very
convenient notation in which to describe
vectors in state space we write down an
element of the Euclidean
three-dimensional
space our and we call this element a
vector and by analogy we write down the
element of state space as vertical bar
psy right angle and we call it a ket
with in Dirac notation the letters R and
sy are simply labels that allow us to
identify the specific vector that we're
working with and they encode all the
information there is to know about those
vectors for example or tells us the
spatial coordinates of a
three-dimensional point and psi
typically contains the necessary
information to describe the quantum
system of interest this could be for
example the energy and momentum of our
system a vector space has two defining
properties the first one is vector
addition and the second one is scalar
multiplication if we start with vector
addition we can write the sum of two
vectors R 1 and R 2 which gives us a
third vector R 3 which also belongs to
the Euclidean three-dimensional space
similarly we can write the sum of two
cats sy 1 and sy 2 as giving us a third
cat sy three which also belongs to the
state space vector addition is
commutative so R 1 plus R 2 is equal to
R 2 plus R 1 and we have an equivalent
expression in terms of cats in state
space vector addition is also
associative which means that R 1 plus R
2 plus R 3 is equal to R 1 plus R 2 plus
R 3 and similarly we can write this down
in state space there is an identity for
vector addition which is the zero vector
such that 0 plus R is equal to R and the
equivalent expression in state space is
0 plus I equals I where the identity in
vector addition for the state space is
called the null ket finally vector
addition has an inverse so R plus it's
inverse gives us the 0 vector and
similarly a cat plus is inverse gives us
the null ket the second defining
property of vector spaces is scalar
multiplication what scalar
multiplication tells us is that we can
take a scalar a multiplied by a vector R
and the result is also a vector that
belongs to R 3 and similarly we can take
scalar a multiplied by a cat side and
the result is also a ket that belongs to
the state space
scalar multiplication is associative
which means that a times P times R is
equal to a B times R and similarly in
state space it is also distributive in
scalar subs which means that a plus B
times R is equal to a R plus B R and
similarly in state space and scalar
multiplication is also distributive in
vector sums so a times R 1 plus R 2 is
equal to a R 1 plus a R 2 and of course
similarly we have the expression in
state space finally we have the identity
for scalar multiplication which is 1
such that 1 times R is equal to R and 1
times sine is equal to psi so that's it
for the refresher on vector spaces where
we have compared the familiar Euclidean
three-dimensional space to the newly
introduced state space where quantum
systems live now that we have defined
the vector space in which quantum
systems live we want to be able to
manipulate the vectors in this space in
order to describe physical phenomena one
important structure that we're going to
associate with state space is the scalar
product and what we're going to do again
is to first introduce the scalar product
in the context of the familiar Euclidean
three-dimensional space the scalar
product SP between two vectors R 1 and R
2 gives us a scalar C which is a real
number and another way in which we
typically write the scalar product in
the three-dimensional euclidean space is
in terms of the dot product R 1 dot R 2
the scalar product comes with the number
of properties and the first one is
conjugation this name may not seem
obvious to start with but it will become
clear later on in this video
conjugation tells us that the scalar
product between R 1 and R 2 is equal to
the scalar product between R 2 and R 1
we can also write that in terms of the
dot product as R 1 dot R 2 equals R 2
dot R 1 the second property is linearity
in the second argument that tells us
that the scalar product between R 1 and
a R 2 where a is a scalar is equal to a
times the scalar product of R 1 with R 2
and again we can write it down in terms
of the dot product in the first argument
becomes scalar product of a r1 r2 is
equal to a and the scalar product of r1
and r2 with again an equivalent
expression in terms of the dot product
and finally linearity also tells us that
the scalar product between r1 and r2
plus r3 is equal to the scalar product
between r1 and r2 plus the scalar
product between r1 and r3 we can
similarly write this down in terms of
dot products the final property of the
scalar product is positivity which tells
us that the scalar product of a vector
with itself is large or equal to zero we
can again write this down in terms of
the dot product or in terms of the
absolute value squared of the vector
positivity also tells us that the scalar
product of a vector with itself is equal
to 0 if and only if the vector itself is
equal to 0 after this reminder about the
scalar product in the usual euclidean
three-dimensional space we're now ready
to move on to the scalar product in
state space the scalar product SP
between psi and Phi gives us a scalar C
and in this case the scalar is a complex
number because state space is a complex
vector space this highlight the crucial
difference between the Euclidian
three-dimensional space which is a real
vector space and state space which is a
complex vector space this difference
will now become obvious when we look at
the properties of the scalar product in
state space conjugation tells us that
the scalar product between sy and Phi is
equal to the scalar product between Phi
and PSI complex conjugate and now this
clarifies why this property is called
conjugation if we now go to the second
property of the scalar product we
realize that the scalar product in state
space is linear only in the second
argument this can be seen in the first
expression and also in the second
expression if you remember the scalar
product in the Euclidean
three-dimensional space was linear in
both the first and the second arguments
but here we're specifying that the
scalar product in the state space is
linear only in the second argument why
is that the reason for that is because
if we combine conjugation with linearity
in the second argument
we arrive at the new condition which
depends on the first two so we call it
to prime and this condition tells us
that the scalar product in state space
is anti linear in the first argument to
see that let's write scalar product of
APE sci fi with a noose conjugation to
write it down as the scalar product of
Phi Apes I star we then use linearity in
the second argument to write it down as
a star scalar product of Phi with side
star and then we use conjugation again
to write it down as a star scalar
product of side with Phi so we see in
Lee that if the scalar is in the first
argument to take it out of the scalar
product we actually need to calculate
its complex conjugate and that's why we
call it anti linear in the first
argument the final property positivity
is easier to carry through from a real
to complex vector space the scalar
product of a cat with itself is a real
number that is large or equal to 0 and
it is equal to 0 if and only if we have
the null ket so what we have seen is
that the scalar product in state space
is quite similar to the scalar product
in the Euclidean space with the main
difference arising because we have a
complex vector space to introduce the
next idea I want to tell you about I
want to revisit the scalar product in
the Euclidean 3-dimensional space if I
write it down as a dot product or one
dot r2 equals C then r1 and r2 appear to
both be vectors in the vector space but
you also know that we can write the
scalar product in the usual Euclidean
3-dimensional space as a matrix
multiplication in this case the scalar C
is simply X 1 Y 1 plus X 2 y 2 plus X 3
y 3 now when we write scalar product in
this form the two terms in the scalar
product actually look different the
first one will you recall a row vector
and the second one we usually call a
column vector what is this telling us we
know that we cannot add a row vector to
a column vector and therefore vector
addition is not properly defined between
row vectors and column vectors this must
mean that they belong to different
vector spaces because vector addition is
a defining property of a vector space
this difference between the two elements
in the scalar product is not always
discussed when discussing a Euclidean
3-dimensional space because when
written in terms of the dot product it
is not obvious that r1 and r2 are
actually different however this
distinction is very important when we
consider state space and that's why I
want to make it here what we're going to
say from now on is that the column
vector belongs to the vector space where
the row vector belongs to the dual space
and in this way we're going to
distinguish between these two different
vector spaces if we want to be a bit
more rigorous when we look at these
spaces we have to introduce the idea of
a linear map in this language what we
say is that a row vector Maps a column
vector to a scalar to make it explicit
for the scalar product what we do is we
write SP or 1 comma dot where the dot
here can in fact represent any vector
and we say that that map's or to to a
scalar see in this particular case that
means that we replace the dot with r2
and then we obtain C by calculating the
scalar product in this language the row
vector and equivalently SP r1 comma dot
are objects that act on vectors in our
vector space and as a result of that
action we obtain a scalar these objects
that act on vector spaces are called
linear maps a question that we could ask
now is whether there is any relationship
between these linear maps and the
vectors in our vector space the answer
is yes in fact there is a one-to-one
correspondence between the two for every
column vector we have a corresponding
row vector that we can simply build by
turning the column into a row so that
means that for every element in our
vector space every column vector there
is a corresponding element that is a
linear map the row vector in the SP
language we say that for every vector R
there is a corresponding linear map SP R
comma dot so what does this all mean
what we see is that the linear maps
themselves from a collection of objects
and in fact it can be shown that the set
of all linear maps forms itself a vector
space to do it what you have to do is
what we did at the beginning of this
video which is to confirm that this
element by a vector addition and scalar
multiplication which are the defining
properties of a vector space what we say
now is that the dual space
is simply the vector space made of the
linear maps that act on the original
vector space if this last slide was a
bit too technical for your taste don't
worry all you have to remember is that
for every column vector there is a
corresponding row vector and then that
combination gives you the scalar product
now that we have identified the dual
space to the Euclidean three-dimensional
vector space we want to identify what is
the dual space to the state space again
we're going to use the scalar product to
make the connection and in this case the
scalar product of Phi with Phi gives us
a scalar which is a complex number
like before we want to identify the
scalar product as a linear map and we
write it down as SP psycho-man thought
where the dot represent an arbitrary ket
that in the example above is simplified
and now we know that this linear map is
simply an element in the dual space of
the state space and we're going to label
it in the following way left angle sy
vertical bar so it is symbol that in a
sense is dual to the symbol for a cat in
Dirac notation in the rack notation we
call the elements of the dual space -
the state space brass and you can think
of them as simply doing the same thing
that row vectors do in the 3-dimensional
Euclidean space with the definition of
an element in the dual space as a bra we
can now rewrite the scalar product in
the rack notation we do that by writing
left angle sine vertical bar Phi right
angle and we call the combination of a
bra and the ket in this way a bracket
and to be absolutely clear what we have
said is that for a cat sy that belongs
to state space we have a corresponding
bra sy that belongs to the dual space
and we call the dual space V star in the
case of column and row vectors in the
usual Euclidean space all we had to do
to go from one to the other was to
change from a column to a row when we
want to relate the cat to a bra there is
an extra subtlety that we have to
consider and that arises from the fact
that the relation between the two spaces
comes from the scalar product and the
scalar product in a complex vector space
is in fact anti linear in the first
argument what that means is affricate
Apes i the corresponding bra is a star
sy
if the ideas I have introduced in this
video will completely new to you then it
is absolutely normal if they take a
while to sink in so don't worry the best
way to learn about new ideas is to
practice practice practice I use Dirac
notation in pretty much all of my videos
so take a look just to get more familiar
with the formalism and once that has
happened maybe revisit this video and
they will be clearer to summarize we
have introduced the state space which is
a complex vector space in which quantum
systems live and we have defined the
elements in this state space as cats and
within Dirac notation a ket is
represented by a vertical bar symbol and
right angle we have also defined the
dual space to the state space whose
elements are brass and we represent them
in Dirac notation as left angle symbol
vertical bar and the relationship
between cats and brass was enabled by
the scalar product which tells us that
the cat a PSI is related to the bra a
star psi and the fact that we have to
take the complex conjugate of a arises
from the anti linearity of the scalar
product in its first argument the final
idea that we introduced is that of a
bracket which is a combination of a bra
and the cat and it represents the scalar
product what have we learned we have
introduced the idea of state space which
is the vector space in which quantum
systems live we have also learned about
Dirac notation which allows us to
simplify the description of vectors in
this state space the Reg notation is
important because it allows us to make
practical calculations in quantum
mechanics and this is one of the
necessary ingredients to learn more
about this topic if you liked this video
or even like to send suggestions for
future videos please subscribe